und wir schauen an die front in den
osten der ukraine dorthin wo die
gefechte derzeit am heftigsten toben in
denen donkers dorthin ist jetzt
präsident wo leute mir sie lenz gereist
und die soldaten zu ehren der präsident
war auch in der stadt sapori chia die
jetzt nach erbitterten kämpfen wieder zu
70 prozent zurück in ukrainischen händen
ist und man werde den don was weiter mit
aller kraft verteidigen sagt der
präsident
die russische armee fassung zusätzliche
kräfte in den on mars zu verlegen aber
es ist der 100 dritte kriegstag der
ukrainische donders steht er steht
entschlossen wir tun alles für die
verteidigung auch in richtung sapori cia
und mikolaj
er doch unsere reporter berichten direkt
von der front hier treffen sie eine
panzer abwehr die vision der ukraine und
dickicht des waldes verstecken sie sich
und die soldaten zeigen uns welche
waffen sie ihr land verteidigen obwohl
die selbst raketen entwickeln um
zielgenau ganze panzer inklusive
besatzung zu vernichten morgen dänischen
soldaten fall meines noch mehr moderne
waffensysteme um die russen zu besiegen
diese panzer jäger rakete ist die beste
waffe der ukraine gegen die putin armee
bild an der kriegsfront im osten der
ukraine
der genaue aufenthaltsort darf nicht
genannt werden denn exklusiv zeigen die
soldaten bild ihr geheim gewehr ihrer
eigenkonstruktion der panzer abwehr
lenkwaffe sda ap
ein soldat sitzt im schützengraben drei
kilometer vor ihm stehen die russen vor
ihm ein monitor uns eine konsole mit
einem kabel sind die beiden mit der
rakete verbunden bis zu 75 meter lang
kann der abstand sein die rakete hat
zwei gefechtsköpfe sie durch schlägt
auch modernste panzerungen ein laser
light streit lenkt sie uns ziehen
wenn der abstand 25 bis 50 meter beträgt
hat man zu 99 prozent einen abschuss
romans truppe verteidigt die front seit
kriegsbeginn vorher war er polizist
seine familie liebt 30 kilometer im film
von der front er setzt alles daran seine
heimat zu verteidigen
wir haben hier überall friedlich gelebt
dann kommen die truppen und erzählen uns
sie wollen uns befreien die hälfte der
leute hier spricht russisch warum das
ganze niemand hat sie darum gebeten
und so geht's der widerstand gegen die
russen unbeirrt weiter trotz aller
verluste trotz der härte zwei panzer hat
die truppe mit der svp bereits
abgeschossen ringen aus über vier
kilometern einen weiteren aus fast einem
kilometer entfernung
wir machen weiter bis zum schluss so
lange wie kraft haben denn hinter uns
stehen unsere kinder unsere familien und
die heimat wir wollen nichts anderes
design gehen wir bauen selbst alles
wieder auf
trotz aller verwüstung und trotz allen
leids sind die ukrainischen soldaten
also optimistisch dass sie bald wieder
in frieden leben will
[Musik]
ja